Hi, everybody, Ira here. My voice is weird today. I feel fine.
大家好，我是艾拉。我今天的嗓子有点怪，但我感觉还好。
Heather loved being Mormon, till she and her husband split up. After that, she says, people in the church treated her and her kids differently. She realized she would never have the perfect Mormon family. She was still a believer, but she started secretly doing things that members of the church aren't supposed to do. She slept with men she wasn't married to. She drank. But on the surface, she kept up appearances, lived a double life for years before she quit the church, a double life with occasional moments where she thought she might get found out.
希瑟曾经很爱摩门教，直到她和丈夫离婚。她说，那之后，教会里的人对待她和她孩子的方式就不一样了。她意识到自己永远无法拥有完美的摩门家庭。她依然有信仰，但开始偷偷做一些教会成员不该做的事。她和未婚男子发生关系。她喝酒。但在表面上，她维持着假象，在离开教会前过了多年的双重生活，在这双重生活中，她偶尔会担心自己被发现。
As a Mormon person, you're not supposed to drink coffee. And that seems fairly innocuous, fairly simple. But I was slipping, and I was drinking coffee, and I had gotten myself a coffee before I picked up my kids from school. And they were young enough that they wouldn't understand or get it. And-- oh, my gosh, yeah, and my friend saw me and waved, and started to walk over to the car.
作为一名摩门教徒，你不应该喝咖啡。这看起来相当无害、相当简单。但我越界了，我当时在喝咖啡，我在接孩子放学前给自己买了一杯。他们当时还太小，不懂这些。天哪，我有个朋友看到了我，冲我招手，还向我的车走过来。
Saw you come out of a coffee shop?
看见你从咖啡店出来？
No, she just saw me in the car pool line, standing there. But I had a hot coffee in my car, and it was fall. And that meant, if I unrolled the window, the smell of coffee was going to waft out and smack her in the face. And so I started to panic, and I unrolled the window. And I can remember the panic. And you just learn to lie so easily and so quickly. And I think I said, oh, I'm not drinking it. I just love the smell in fall. Don't worry, don't worry. I just love the smell.
不，她只是在拼车点看到了我，站在那儿。但我车里有一杯热咖啡，当时是秋天。这意味着，如果我摇下车窗，咖啡的味道就会飘出去扑到她脸上。所以我开始恐慌，但我还是摇下了车窗。我记得那种恐慌。你真的会学会如何轻易且迅速地撒谎。我想我说的是，噢，我没喝，我只是喜欢秋天里咖啡的味道。别担心，别担心。我只是喜欢这个味道。
And she accepted that and said, oh, I do too, isn't it so tempting? And we both just kind of sat there. Obviously, I didn't buy a coffee for the smell. It was just a conversation that was completely fake, and we both engaged in it.
她接受了这个说法，说，噢，我也喜欢，这味道多诱人啊？我们俩就在那儿坐着。显然，我买咖啡不是为了闻味儿。那完全是一场虚假的对话，我们俩都参与其中。
And so when she said, oh, it's so tempting, did you take it as her saying, this is our secret, I love you, we're good?
所以当她说“太诱人了”的时候，你是把它理解为她在说：这是我们的秘密，我爱你，我们没问题吗？
I took it as her, saying, I'm going to pretend to believe your lie, because it's an easier path for both of us. And I think my kids probably did that a lot, too, pretended to believe my lies.
我把它理解为她在说：我打算假装相信你的谎言，因为这对我们俩来说都是条轻松的路。我想我的孩子们可能也经常这样做，假装相信我的谎言。
This is actually why I wanted to talk to Heather. Our show today is about how different members of the family perceive the same events differently. And what was happening inside Heather's family during those years seemed like such an extreme example of that, because she was trying to deceive her kids. She was raising three daughters on her own, raising them in the church, she says, to be the perfect, pure vessels of Mormonism for their future husbands. Her words, not mine.
其实这就是我想找希瑟谈话的原因。我们今天的节目是关于家庭成员如何以不同的方式看待同一事件。而希瑟那些年在家中所发生的一切，似乎是一个极端的例子，因为她试图欺骗她的孩子们。她独自抚养三个女儿，在教会中抚养她们，她说，是为了让她们成为未来丈夫所期待的、完美纯洁的摩门教容器。这是她的话，不是我的。
This is partly because it was the only way she knew how to be a mother. But also, Heather loved her own childhood growing up in the church. She wanted to give that to them. And Heather wasn't just still a believer. She's the kind of try-hard, can-do believer who became Relief Society President in her ward, which meant that she ministered to the women in about 150 families. Heather stood at a pulpit every Sunday, teaching Mormon doctrine. And she did that knowing that her kids sometimes saw her break the rules.
这部分是因为这是她所知的唯一做母亲的方式。但也因为希瑟热爱自己在教会长大的童年。她想把这些给她们。而且希瑟不仅仅是有信仰。她是那种非常努力、事事亲力亲为的信徒，后来成了她所在教区的慈助会会长，这意味着她要照顾大约150个家庭的女性。希瑟每周日都站在讲台上，教授摩门教义。她这样做的时候，很清楚自己的孩子有时会看到她违背教规。
Like, for example, after her divorce, she stopped wearing the special Mormon undergarments that adults are supposed to wear. Her kids knew that she didn't wear them.
比如，离婚后，她不再穿成年人必须穿的摩门教特制内衣。她的孩子们知道她没穿。
Because they would see me change, and I didn't have them on.
因为她们会看到我换衣服，而我并没有穿那些。
And do you remember any moments where they saw this, and they asked?
你还记得她们看到这些并问起的时候吗？
No, they never asked. They never said a word.
不，她们从没问过。她们一个字也没提。
What do you make of that?
你是怎么看的？
I don't even know what to make of that. First, I feel like they probably felt confused. And also, I would think resentment, because I was a strict mom, and I held them to the standard of appearances at church. And I taught from the pulpit, I taught gospel doctrine. And then for them to go home and see that the words coming out of my mouth did not match the simplest of actions, like the type of underwear I was wearing.
我甚至不知道该怎么看。首先，我觉得她们可能感到困惑。还有，我想是怨恨，因为我是一个严厉的母亲，我要求她们在教会保持完美形象。我在讲台上讲课，教授福音教义。然后她们回家看到，我嘴里说的话与我最简单的行为——比如我穿的内裤类型——完全不符。
Do you think that they weren't saying anything, because it's just one of those things when you're a kid sometimes, where you don't even know what it means, but you just know, don't go there?
你觉得她们什么都不说，是因为小孩子有时候就是这样，他们甚至不知道这意味着什么，但他们只知道：别去碰那个话题？
Yeah, I think that's exactly what it was. I think it was laden with meaning, and so they knew not to ask.
是的，我觉得正是如此。这充满了含义，所以她们知道不要去问。
Mostly, Heather tried to keep things on the down low from her kids. She kept a bottle of vodka hidden in the house, high on the third shelf of a closet, with sweaters and other clothes that she was sure the girls didn't go into. And she says there were no visible clues of her secret life in the house.
大多数时候，希瑟尽量不让孩子们发现。她在家里把一瓶伏特加藏在壁橱第三层的高处，用毛衣和其他衣服遮着，她确信女儿们不会去那里。她说家里没有任何她私生活的可见迹象。
Until my business partner bought me a Keurig.
直到我的生意伙伴给我买了一台Keurig咖啡机。
Keurig, the little coffee maker?
Keurig，那个小型咖啡机？
The little coffee maker, the counter coffee maker. And I immediately went out and bought a tier with all of the herbal teas and hot chocolates, because those are kosher. And I made sure that those were on display. And for years, every time someone would come to my house, the first thing I would do is gesture to the Keurig, to the coffee maker, and say, we love this for hot cocoa, for the kids. I would lead with that, because it was just such, to me, a blaring symbol of rebellion and slipping.
那个小型咖啡机，柜台上的咖啡机。我立刻跑出去买了一个架子，上面放满了草药茶和热巧克力，因为那些是符合教规的。我确保把那些摆在显眼处。多年来，每当有人来我家，我做的第一件事就是指着Keurig咖啡机说，我们喜欢用它冲热可可给孩子们喝。我会先发制人，因为对我来说，这简直是一个极其显眼的叛逆和越界的标志。
Where were the coffee pods hidden?
咖啡胶囊藏在哪儿了？
They were deep in the pantry in-- honestly, it's a Cheez-Its multi-pack box. Because with the kids lunches, you get the bigger boxes, and then you could just take out all the single serves, and you just put them in it.
它们藏在储藏室深处的……老实说，是一个Cheez-Its饼干的大包装盒里。因为买孩子们的午餐用品时，你会得到更大的盒子，然后你可以把里面的独立包装取出来，直接放进去就行了。
And then, was the scheme that once the kids were off at school, you were home alone, and you could put the little Keurig capsule in and make yourself a coffee? Or were you--
那么，你的计划是，一旦孩子们去上学了，你一个人在家，就可以放进Keurig胶囊给自己煮杯咖啡了？还是说——
I was doing it first thing in the morning.
我大清早就开始煮了。
You would do it first thing in the morning?
你大清早就煮？
Yeah, I was doing it first thing in the morning, and they could smell it. And I don't know how to explain it. It's like-- I assumed they wouldn't know what it was because they had never been exposed to it. They didn't see coffee at their friends' houses. They didn't--
是的，我一大早就煮，她们能闻到。我不知道该怎么解释。就好像……我假设她们不会知道那是什么味道，因为她们从未接触过。她们在朋友家没见过咖啡。她们没有——
Oh, that didn't even occur to me.
噢，我甚至没考虑到这一点。
This is the world they-- it's no like coffee--
这就是她们的世界……那里没有咖啡——
They don't live in a world with coffee.
她们生活在一个没有咖啡的世界里。
They don't live in a world with coffee. So you can get away with lying about a lot of things.
她们生活在一个没有咖啡的世界里。所以你在很多事情上撒谎都能瞒天过海。
Oh, so your 10-year-old isn't smelling coffee and thinking it's coffee. Your 10-year-old is smelling coffee and just thinking--
噢，所以你10岁的孩子闻到咖啡味并不会想到是咖啡。你10岁的孩子闻到咖啡味只是觉得——
It's a smell. And I mean, she might have been making the connection all along. But it was a don't ask, don't tell, don't acknowledge policy.
那只是一种味道。我是说，也许她一直以来都知道是怎么回事。但这是一种“不问、不说、不承认”的潜规则。
Your oldest is Ashley?
你的长女是阿什莉？
Yeah, Ashley. She's 22 now.
是的，阿什莉。她现在22岁了。
Oh, my God. I want to ask her.
噢，天哪。我想问问她。
Yeah, you should.
行，你应该问问。
So I reached out to Ashley. She was 12 the year they got the Keurig. Her little sisters were 9 and 8. She came into the studio. And from the moment I brought up the Keurig, her memory was totally different from her mom's.
所以我联系了阿什莉。她们买Keurig那年她12岁。她的妹妹们分别是9岁和8岁。她来到录音室。从我提起Keurig的那一刻起，她的记忆就和她妈妈的完全不同。
Guess who gave her the Keurig?
猜猜是谁给了她这台Keurig？
Who?
谁？
Me.
我。
Heather, as you heard, remembers it was her business partner. But Ashley said, no. She had money she'd earned babysitting. It was the first big, grown up Christmas present she ever bought her mom.
正如你听到的，希瑟记得是她的生意伙伴给的。但阿什莉说，不是。那是她用当保姆赚的钱买的。那是她买给妈妈的第一份大人的、昂贵的圣诞礼物。
I can't believe she didn't tell you that I was the one that got it. It was a big deal. I saved up my money to get her this Keurig.
我简直不敢相信她没告诉你是我买的。这可是件大事。我攒钱买了这台Keurig送给她。
And when you bought the Keurig, what did you think it was for?
那你买这台Keurig的时候，你以为它是用来干什么的？
For coffee.
为了喝咖啡。
As she said, she got the idea for this at her friend Elsha's house. Elsha and she were best friends, debate partners. And their moms got to know each other and went into business together. Elsha's family was ex-Mormon, so Ashley would see Elsha's parents drink coffee, or go to the store or the gym on Sunday, which Mormons aren't supposed to do on the Sabbath. And they seem normal and happy, and those things did not seem harmful to their family at all.
正如她说的那样，这个想法是她从朋友埃尔莎家得来的。埃尔莎和她是最好的朋友，辩论搭档。她们的妈妈也认识，还一起做了生意。埃尔莎的家庭是前摩门教徒，所以阿什莉会看到埃尔莎的父母喝咖啡，或者在周日去商店或健身房，而摩门教徒在安息日是不该做这些的。他们看起来很正常、很幸福，这些事情对他们的家庭来说一点坏处都没有。
I was so fascinated by having a glass of wine at dinner, seeing parents just having a glass of wine at dinner. And I don't know how to explain it. It felt cool, very cool. And I-- I want my family to be like this. I was with them a lot growing up. And having a Keurig in the house was so normal. And seeing that, I'm like, why can't we have that?
我对晚餐时喝杯红酒感到特别着迷，看到父母在晚餐时喝杯酒。我不知道怎么解释。这感觉很酷，非常酷。而且……我希望我的家庭也能这样。我小时候经常和他们在一起。家里有台Keurig显得太正常了。看到这些，我就想，为什么我们不能有呢？
So you bought it for your mom, understanding, my mom drinks coffee, I'm buying this for her so she can have coffee.
所以你买给妈妈，理解就是：我妈喝咖啡，我买这个给她，这样她就能喝咖啡了。
Yes. Like I want you to drink coffee. Like me buying her a Keurig, I think she kind of thought, oh, my gosh, Ashley understands me. I'm seen by my daughter, and supported in a way. Like it wasn't-- I was on the same wavelength. Like, yeah, let's get a Keurig.
是的。就像我希望你喝咖啡。我觉得我给她买Keurig时，她大概心想：噢，天哪，阿什莉懂我。我被女儿看穿了，并以某种方式得到了支持。就像……我们在同一个频道上。比如，是的，我们买台Keurig吧。
She had no idea that her mom didn't remember it this way at all. But she said she was so young, it was very possible that she never told her Mom, this is for you to drink coffee, I know you drink coffee.
她完全不知道她妈妈的记忆和她完全不一样。但她说她当时太小了，很有可能她从来没告诉过她妈妈：这是给你喝咖啡用的，我知道你喝咖啡。
Honestly, because I was 12, I don't-- I guess I wouldn't up and say that.
老实说，因为我那时才12岁，我……我想我不会站出来这么说的。
So do you think what might have happened-- I just am trying to get this straight. So you think you might have given her the Keurig, understanding what the Keurig is for, but she didn't get the hint?
所以你觉得可能发生了什么——我只是想弄清楚这点。所以你觉得你可能给了她这台咖啡机，明白它的用途，但她没领会你的暗示？
I think maybe that's what's going on here. Yeah. Or she didn't want to believe that I saw that side of her.
我想也许就是这么回事。是的。或者她不想相信我看到了她那一面。
Oh, that's so interesting. She couldn't understand what you were trying to show her, because she wasn't ready for it?
噢，这太有趣了。她无法理解你想展示给她看的东西，因为她还没准备好？
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, your mom said to me that you and your sisters were properly raised Mormon children, and she was betting on the fact that you hadn't been exposed to coffee at friends' houses or elsewhere. So when you would smell coffee at home, you guys wouldn't even know it was coffee.
我是说，你妈妈告诉我，你和妹妹们是典型的摩门教教养下的孩子，她押注在你们没在朋友家或其他地方接触过咖啡上。所以当你们在家闻到咖啡味时，你们甚至不知道那是咖啡。
Oh, she said that?
噢，她那么说的？
Yes.
是的。
OK. Yeah, I think she's underestimating what I knew about the world at that time.
好吧。是的，我想她低估了当时我对这个世界的了解。
So Ashley and her mom were in this situation where they each saw why the Keurig arrived very differently. But at the time, each of them thought they both saw it the same way, which is so weird that I wondered about Ashley's sisters. Again, they were 8 and 9 when the Keurig arrived.
所以阿什莉和她妈妈处于这样一种境地：她们各自对Keurig出现的原因理解完全不同。但在当时，她们都以为对方的想法和自己一样，这太奇怪了，所以我很好奇阿什莉的妹妹们。再说一次，Keurig出现时她们才8岁和9岁。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
We called her youngest sister.
我们给最小的妹妹打了电话。
Hello?
喂？
Blue?
布鲁？
Who remembers the Keurig this way--
谁是这样记得Keurig的——
We only used it for hot chocolate, and I can't-- yeah, I don't think she used it for coffee at all.
我们只用它来冲热可可，我不能……是的，我觉得她根本没用它冲过咖啡。
So when Ashley got her the Keurig, as far as you understood, that was a machine for cocoa?
所以当阿什莉给她买了那台Keurig时，在你看来，那是一台冲可可的机器？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Hot chocolate machine.
热巧克力机。
Your mom explained to me that she was drinking coffee out of it all the time, and she was just betting on the fact that you just didn't know what coffee smelled like. Is that possible?
你妈妈向我解释说，她一直都在用那机器煮咖啡喝，她只是赌你们不知道咖啡是什么味儿。这可能吗？
Oh, yeah. No, that could definitely be true. Because I didn't know what coffee smelled like, and I didn't notice at all. So that's crazy. I didn't know that.
噢，是的。不，那绝对是真的。因为我确实不知道咖啡是什么味道，我一点也没察觉。这太疯狂了。我不知道这点。
Yeah. Your mom said she was drinking coffee in the house all the time, making it all the time.
是的。你妈妈说她一直在家里煮咖啡喝，一直都在煮。
What? Wow. Yeah, I had no idea. That's mind blowing to me. Yeah, I totally thought she only started drinking it a couple years ago. I mean, when we left the church.
什么？哇。是的，我完全不知道。这对我来说太震撼了。是的，我一直以为她是在几年前才开始喝的。我是说，当我们离开教会之后。
Can I blow your mind with one other piece of information?
我能再告诉你一个让你震惊的消息吗？
Yes, please.
好的，请说。
Ask your sister Ashley if she knew.
问问你姐姐阿什莉她知不知道。
Did you know, Ashley?
你知道吗，阿什莉？
Yes. I'm actually mind blown that you thought that she just started drinking coffee a few years ago. You had no idea?
知道。说实话，你觉得她是几年前才开始喝咖啡的，这太让我震惊了。你真的完全没察觉？
No.
没有。
What?
什么？
Yeah, what? Wait, that's crazy. Yeah, because I thought it was such a huge sin, mom would never do that. That's crazy.
是的，什么？等等，这太疯狂了。是的，因为我一直觉得那是天大的罪过，妈妈绝对不会做那种事。这太疯狂了。
Oh, my gosh, this is blowing my mind.
噢，天哪，这让我大开眼界。
Yeah, I'm mind blown. I can't believe that. I can't believe that!
是的，我也被惊到了。我不敢相信！我不敢相信！
I'm dead.
我彻底无语了。
That's insane, that's insane.
这太疯狂了，太疯狂了。
This is as good a time as any to tell you that Heather is on a TV show. If you know the show, I'm guessing that maybe you've already figured that out. Heather is Heather Gay, one of The Real Housewives of Salt Lake City, kind of an audience favorite from that show. And one of the things that comes out on that show, and in two books that Heather's written, is the shame that she sometimes still feels, the fear of judgment, when she's not following the church's rules.
现在正好可以告诉你，希瑟正在参加一个电视节目。如果你知道这个节目，我猜你可能已经猜到了。希瑟就是希瑟·盖伊，《盐湖城真正的家庭主妇》中的一员，在该节目中颇受观众喜爱。在那档节目以及希瑟写的两本书中，流露出的一件事是她有时仍感到的羞耻感，以及当她不遵守教会教规时对被审判的恐惧。
What was interesting about talking to Heather's three kids-- I also talked to her third daughter, Georgia-- was that they felt none of that. None. They'd always seen themselves as one of those Mormon families that bends the rules. They'd always stop to do things like pick up Mexican food after church on Sunday, even though you're not supposed to get takeout on Sabbath. The mom not wearing church undergarments wasn't a big deal to them. They thought that rule was silly anyway.
关于和希瑟的三个孩子谈话，有趣的一点是——我也和她的三女儿乔治亚谈过——她们完全没有这种感觉。完全没有。她们一直把自己视为那种会变通教规的摩门家庭。她们总是会在周日礼拜后停下来买墨西哥菜，尽管安息日不该买外卖。妈妈不穿教会内衣对她们来说也不是什么大事。她们觉得那条规矩本身就很傻。
Ashley always figured she and her mom both felt hemmed in by the church.
阿什莉一直觉得她和她妈妈都感到被教会束缚住了。
Like I just understood her. I could see that it just wasn't her, that she wanted something different.
就像我能理解她一样。我能看出那根本不是她，她想要的是别的东西。
Ashley and I picked up the phone one more time, to call her mom.
阿什莉和我又拿起电话，拨给了她妈妈。
This is the best day ever. I'm really enjoying this.
这是最好的一天。我真的很享受这一切。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
And Ashley told Heather what she told me, that she was the one who bought the Keurig, and that she did it knowing that her mom drank coffee, trying to say, go ahead, drink coffee at home. That's fine with me. This, of course, was news to Heather.
阿什莉告诉了希瑟她刚才告诉我的事：是她买了Keurig，而且她买的时候就知道妈妈喝咖啡，试图表达“没关系，你在家喝吧，我不介意”。这当然是希瑟第一次听说。
I don't know why it's making me emotional. I just-- it feels like you're kind of giving me permission to be myself, and I-- I didn't know all of that behind it. I didn't know that.
我不知道为什么这让我这么情绪化。我只是……感觉你好像给了我做回自己的许可，而我……我根本不知道这一切背后的意义。我不知道。
You didn't? That makes me want to cry, too.
你不知道？那也让我好想哭。
I didn't.
我不知道。
Aw. I really-- I can't believe we never had that conversation. That was totally-- totally what it was.
噢。我真的……我不敢相信我们从来没进行过那种对话。那完全……完全就是那样。
Probably because I felt like I couldn't embrace it, because I felt somehow that I was letting you down, letting the church down, letting down your sisters by being brazen in something that I wasn't allowed to drink. And a good mom doesn't have a Keurig. And I was already a bad mom because I'd gotten divorced, and I was already a bad mom because I was working. I was just trying to cling to the standards that I thought-- that I'd been told defined a good person from a bad person.
大概是因为我感觉自己无法拥抱它，因为我觉得以某种方式我是在让你失望，让教会失望，让你的姐妹们失望，因为我厚颜无耻地喝了不被允许喝的东西。好妈妈是不会用Keurig的。我已经因为离婚成了坏妈妈，因为我出去工作已经是坏妈妈了。我只是试图紧紧抓住那些曾定义“好人与坏人”的标准。
But it's funny, by giving you the Keurig, Ashley is trying to say, I know you drink coffee. Do you think you just weren't ready to hear that from Ashley?
但很有趣，阿什莉通过给你买Keurig试图说：我知道你喝咖啡。你觉得你只是还没准备好从阿什莉口中听到这些吗？
I wasn't ready to hear that from-- I didn't admit it to myself. So I definitely wasn't ready to hear it from my daughter, who I was supposed to keep shielded from all of those things. And when I say keep shielded, not from coffee, but from my failings.
我还没准备好从……我自己都没承认这点。所以我当然没准备好从我女儿口中听到，我本来是应该让她们远离所有那些事情的。当我说是远离时，不是远离咖啡，而是远离我的失败。
Oh, no, mom, that breaks my heart that you-- it all breaks my heart. But I just always-- yeah, I understood you, and I feel like we were in the same boat. And when you finally were like, guys, I don't want to go to church anymore, I felt this sense of relief for myself, but also for you, that you don't have to live a lie just for us. You know?
噢，不，妈妈，你说这话让我心碎……这整件事都让我心碎。但我一直……是的，我理解你，我觉得我们是一条船上的。当你最终说“孩子们，我不想再去教会了”的时候，我感到一种如释重负，不仅是为我自己，也是为你，因为你不需要再仅仅为了我们而活在谎言里了。你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And it started with the Keurig.
而这一切是从Keurig开始的。
It started with the Keurig, the gateway.
确实是从Keurig开始的，是那个入门产品。
It did. No, the fact that--
是的。不，事实是——
The gateway appliance.
那个入门级家电。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wait, I still have that Keurig. I still use it.
等等，我还在用那台Keurig。我还在用。
You do? That's the same one? Wait, that makes me want to cry. The Keurig!
你还在用？还是原来那台？等等，这让我好想哭。那台Keurig！
Yeah, 10 years old.
是的，10年了。
Aw.
噢。
People in the same family, people who live under the same roof, can see things so radically differently, even simple things like a coffee maker. Today, on our program, we have another very loving family, two parents, two kids. And they're in this situation, living through the same events, seeing the exact same things that they all have very different takes on. They try to get on the same page, but it's hard.
同一家庭中的人，住在同一屋檐下的人，看待事情的方式可以截然不同，哪怕是咖啡机这样简单的事情。今天，在我们的节目里，还有另一个非常恩爱的家庭，一对父母，两个孩子。他们也处于这种情况，经历着同样的事件，看着完全相同的事情，每个人却有非常不同的解读。他们试图达成共识，但很难。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自WBEZ芝加哥，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act 1, A House Divided.
这是《美国生活》。第一幕，分化的家庭。
There's a spot in McKenzie and Bella's house that's perfect for eavesdropping on their parents, a small sitting nook on the second floor at the top of the stairs. When their parents are downstairs talking in the kitchen or in their bedroom, sound travels up, making its way through the stairwell.
在麦肯齐和贝拉的房子里有个地方非常适合偷听父母说话，二楼楼梯顶端的一个小角落。当她们的父母在楼下厨房或卧室谈话时，声音会传上来，穿过楼梯间。
So you can hear everything that's going on. Or you sit in the rocking chair that's right across the door. So it's like they'll have the door closed, and you can hear murmurs. We're kind of in the shadow, like I know what's going on, but I don't know exact things.
所以你能听到正在发生的一切。或者你可以坐在门对面的摇椅上。就像他们关着门，你能听到低语。我们就像处在阴影中，我知道发生了什么，但不知道确切的细节。
That's McKenzie, she's 17. The girls' parents, Jenni and Fidel, almost never fight. They're one of those families that likes spending time together. They do arts and crafts together, go on road trips and don't kill each other. That kind of family. The girls are close to their parents. So all this disagreement is abnormal in their house. But since last November, when President Trump won the election, they've been in a stalemate over whether Fidel should self-deport, return to Mexico, where he hasn't lived in 30 years.
那是麦肯齐，她17岁。姐妹俩的父母，珍妮和菲德尔，几乎从不吵架。他们是那种喜欢待在一起的家庭。他们一起做手工，一起去公路旅行，而且不会互相折磨。就是那种家庭。姐妹俩和父母很亲。所以这一切不和谐在她们家是非常反常的。但自从去年11月特朗普总统赢得选举以来，她们就陷入了僵局，关于菲德尔是否应该“自愿遣返”，回到他已经30年没住过的墨西哥。
The girls exist on the periphery of this stalemate, living their high school lives during the day, dipping in and out of their parents' discussions at home at night.
姐妹俩存在于这种僵局的边缘，白天过着她们的高中生活，晚上在家里时进进出出地听着父母的讨论。
Sometimes I'll be upstairs, and they'll be discussing stuff, and I'll turn down my music to make sure that I'm not going crazy thinking about what they're talking about, because they seem to be-- it's important.
有时我在楼上，他们在讨论事情，我会调小音乐，确保自己没有因为在想他们说的事情而发疯，因为他们似乎……那很重要。
Here's Bella, she's 15.
这是贝拉，她15岁。
Every once in a while, when I'm watching TV or something, and I'm sitting on the couch, I pause my show and listen for a few minutes, and then I'll be like, OK, cool. That's what's happening. And then I'll turn my show back on. And yeah.
偶尔，当我正在看电视什么的，坐在沙发上时，我会暂停我的节目，听上几分钟，然后心想：好吧，酷。原来是这样。然后我再把节目调回去。是的。
One of our producers, Valerie Kipnis, was interested in how families are making this decision over whether to self-deport, and especially the families of people who do not agree on what to do or how to handle this. She's been following the Riveras for most of this year. The parents were definitely, emphatically not in agreement. They live outside Raleigh, North Carolina. Jenni Rivera is a high school math teacher. She's a citizen, born here, which you might think would mean that her husband, Fidel, who's from Mexico, would have a path to citizenship.
我们的制片人之一，瓦莱丽·基普尼斯，对家庭如何决定是否自愿遣返很感兴趣，尤其是当人们对怎么做或怎么处理意见不一致时。她今年大部分时间都在跟踪里维拉一家。父母显然、绝对没有达成一致。他们住在北卡罗来纳州罗利市外。珍妮·里维拉是一位高中数学老师。她是美国公民，出生在这里，你可能会觉得这意味着她来自墨西哥的丈夫菲德尔会有一条通往公民身份的道路。
But there's a longstanding part of immigration law. Fidel crossed into the States illegally, back when he was 18, left, and came back into the States. And because of that, he cannot get citizenship through Jenni until he spends 10 years living outside the United States. So he's been living in the US without legal status for 30 years. And for most of this year, he's been in a prolonged, high stakes dispute with Jenni over whether to stay here.
但移民法中有一个长期存在的条款。菲德尔18岁时非法越境进入美国，离开后又回到了美国。正因为如此，在他住在美国境外满10年之前，他无法通过珍妮获得公民身份。所以他以非法身份在美国生活了30年。今年大部分时间里，他一直在与珍妮就是否继续留在这里进行着长期的、高风险的争论。
Valerie wanted to see how making this decision would reverberate around the walls of this one house. Not just how Jenni and Fidel would figure out what to do, but how their kids, Bella and McKenzie, would deal with the stress of this choice that was being discussed for months and could upend their entire lives. Here's Valerie.
瓦莱丽想看看这个决定会在这个房子里引发怎样的涟漪。不仅是如何决定怎么做，还要看看孩子们，贝拉和麦肯齐，如何处理这种选择带来的压力，这些压力已经讨论了几个月，而且可能会颠覆她们的整个生活。这是瓦莱丽。
In spite of being incredibly close, McKenzie and Bella are a classic case of opposites. McKenzie has a high, girly laugh, long hair, gold hoops, a senior in high school. Bella, just two years younger, wears baggy shorts and a soccer jersey, and pitches her voice lower in this "yeah, whatever" way when she speaks. Here's Bella.
尽管极其亲密，但麦肯齐和贝拉是典型的截然不同。麦肯齐有着清脆、少女般的笑声，长发，戴着金色圆圈耳环，是高三学生。贝拉小两岁，穿着松垮的短裤和球衣，说话时声音更低沉，带着一种“随便吧”的态度。这是贝拉。
I just like to sit in my room and exist. Honestly, I'm sitting on the couch watching TV. And then she comes and blocks my view, and is like, is this outfit good? Do these shoes match this outfit?
我只是喜欢坐在房间里存在着。老实说，我坐在沙发上看电视。然后她走过来挡住我的视线，问：这套衣服好看吗？这鞋子跟这衣服搭吗？
Does my hair look good?
我头发看起来好吗？
Yeah. But I'll be honest with her. I'll tell her if her hair looks frizzy or something, but.
是的。但我会对她说实话。如果她头发看起来毛躁什么的，我会告诉她。
Yeah.
是的。
On cue, Bella points to her big sister's neck where her necklace has gotten tangled.
应声地，贝拉指着姐姐脖子上缠住的项链。
Your necklace is like--
你的项链好像——
OK, thank you queen.
好的，谢谢女王。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Upstairs are the girls' bedrooms and a little hangout area. Downstairs is the site of their parents disagreement about whether their dad and the family should leave the country, what the girls have been calling "the situation."
楼上是女孩们的卧室和一个小休息区。楼下是父母关于父亲和全家是否应该离开这个国家争执的场所，也就是女孩们所说的“情况”。
Could you tell me about some of the moments that it has come up?
你能告诉我一些它被提起的时刻吗？
Like about the situation? I think that most recently, it's just been like every day. It's mostly because--
关于那个情况？我想最近几乎每天都在说。主要是因为——
[SINGING IN THE BACKGROUND]
[背景音乐中有人在唱歌]
is she singing? She's singing.
她在唱歌吗？她在唱歌。
Yeah, she's singing.
是的，她在唱歌。
The person singing in the background is their mom, Jenni. She's in the room next door, wearing noise canceling headphones, singing the 2015 hit single "Fight Song."
在背景中唱歌的是她们的妈妈珍妮。她在隔壁房间，戴着降噪耳机，唱着2015年的热门单曲《Fight Song》。
OK.
好吧。
好的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, she does that a lot, actually.
嗯，她其实经常这么做。
Every once in a while, I'd be sitting upstairs, and then I hear her voice coming through the floor, and I was like, what is happening? I thought it was a ghost in my room.
偶尔，我坐在楼上，然后听到她的声音从地板传过来，我想：发生了什么？我以为房间里闹鬼了。
Cause my grandma told her it's a good way to distract your mind.
因为我奶奶告诉她，这是分散注意力、舒缓心情的好办法。
Yeah.
是的。
So she does that by singing.
所以她通过唱歌来做这件事。
Jenni's been singing a lot this past year, ever since Donald Trump won the election, because she's stressed about Fidel. She just wanted him to make a plan. Either he should move to Mexico, or they should move together as a family. The one thing they couldn't do, from her perspective, was to keep doing what they had been for the last 16 years, living under the radar.
珍妮过去一年唱了很多歌，自从唐纳德·特朗普赢得选举以来，因为她为菲德尔感到压力很大。她只是希望他能制定一个计划。要么他搬回墨西哥，要么他们全家一起搬走。在她看来，他们唯一不能做的就是继续过去16年的做法，即保持低调。
That wasn't working for me anymore. Just doing what we're doing wasn't working. I needed to have a plan in place in case something happened.
那对我来说再也行不通了。仅仅做我们正在做的事情是不够的。我需要制定一个计划，以防万一。
Jenni is a rule follower. For 16 years, she worried when Fidel drove to work without a license, that he'd get into an accident and their insurance wouldn't cover it, or he'd get stopped by police and end up in detention. The only way Jenni had been able to sleep at night was because a lawyer had told them that if Fidel got picked up in that situation, it wasn't hopeless. They could go in front of a judge and argue for Fidel. He's got a great job, no criminal record. Dad of two, married to a US citizen. Maybe they could make their case for him to stay.
珍妮是个循规蹈矩的人。16年来，每当菲德尔无证开车上班时，她都很担心，担心他会出事故而保险不理赔，或者他会被警察拦下并最终被拘留。珍妮能安然入睡的唯一原因是一位律师曾告诉他们，如果菲德尔在那样的情况下被抓，也不是绝望的。他们可以在法官面前为菲德尔辩护。他有一份很好的工作，没有犯罪记录。两个孩子的父亲，和一个美国公民结婚。也许他们能为他留下来争取到机会。
We had a-- one card to play. That's what I call it. It was just like we had one-- we had one ace in the hole that we could play.
我们当时只有……一张底牌可以打。这就是我所说的。就像我们有……我们有一个王牌可以打。
In Trump's second term, that option would probably go away. And if Fidel got picked up, he'd probably be detained and deported. Jenni couldn't see a path forward. Fidel, however, saw it differently. Trump hadn't even taken office yet. He thought she was overreacting.
在特朗普的第二个任期，这个选项可能会消失。如果菲德尔被抓，他很可能会被拘留并驱逐出境。珍妮看不出有什么出路。然而，菲德尔的看法不同。特朗普甚至还没上任。他觉得她反应过度了。
It's like, are you crazy? I'm not going to go nowhere. It's even like I told her, it's like I've been here for 30 years, and nothing happened. It's like I've never been to jail. I never been in a bad accident. I just go to work and coming back. What you need to worry about too much? Always thinking like I'm going to prove you wrong, it's not going to happen.
就像是，你疯了吗？我哪里也不去。就像我告诉她的，我在那儿待了30年了，什么都没发生。我从没坐过牢。我从没出过严重事故。我只是去上班，然后回家。你为什么担心那么多？总是想着我会证明你是错的，这不会发生的。
When I first started talking to Fidel and Jenni over the phone, this is where they were, at an impasse.
当我第一次通过电话与菲德尔和珍妮谈话时，他们正处于这个境地，僵持不下。
Right now, she's the one like, what are we going to do, what are we going to do? I think some part of my brain is like a lack of something.
现在，她是那种……我们该怎么办，我们该怎么办？我想我的大脑某部分是缺乏某种东西。
Because you feel like there's time pressure?
因为你觉得有时间压力？
Yeah. The time and the-- I don't want to--
是的。时间和……我不想——
And his wife is driving him nuts.
而且他的妻子让他抓狂。
And my wife's driving me nuts. My wife is--
我的妻子让我抓狂。我的妻子是——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Getting mad, because he's sticking his head in the sand.
生气，因为他把头埋在沙子里。
Sticking my head in the sand. But like I said, I try to not think in that way. But like I said, we are-- we are totally different persons.
把头埋在沙子里。但正如我所说，我尽量不那样想。但正如我所说，我们是……我们是完全不同的人。
These are the conversations the girls were overhearing.
这些就是女孩们在偷听的对话。
Fidel and Jenni have been married 17 years. Happily. They met salsa dancing. He stepped on her foot. She said, you owe me an ice cream. They spent the night talking at Denny's. These days, they still salsa dance in the living room, and corner off weekend mornings just for talking. When I asked Fidel to describe who's who in the relationship, this is how he frames the answer.
菲德尔和珍妮结婚17年了。很幸福。他们在跳萨尔萨舞时相识。他踩了她的脚。她说，你欠我一个冰淇淋。他们聊了一整晚。这些天，他们仍然在客厅跳萨尔萨舞，并留出周末早晨专门谈话。当我请菲德尔描述两人的关系时，他是这样表达的。
I always tell her it's is the positive and the negative. It's the positive and the negative.
我总是告诉她，这就是正极和负极。这就是正极和负极。
Because you're an electrician, it's funny that you're saying positive and negative, because that's--
因为你是电工，你说正极和负极很有意思，因为那是——
Yeah. It's like how the battery works, how the car works. Because I always think positive. But she always looks at reality. She's the one saving money. She's the one making sure everything in the house works. All the paperwork is right, make sure the girls got the ride to school.
是的。就像电池怎么工作，汽车怎么工作。因为我总是想得很积极。但她总是看现实。她是那个存钱的人。她是那个确保家里一切运转正常的人。所有文书工作都准确无误，确保孩子们有车接送上学。
Jenni posts to-do lists around the house. He executes, crossing each item off as he goes along. That's how they both like it.
珍妮会在家里贴待办事项列表。他负责执行，每完成一项就勾掉一项。他们俩都喜欢这样。
He is the fun dad. He does all the fun things. He takes the kids out for ice cream, and he spoils them. And if it's the disciplinarian, that's me.
他是那个有趣的爸爸。他做所有好玩的事。他带孩子们去吃冰淇淋，宠着她们。如果要说严厉的管教者，那是我。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He is not the disciplinarian at all.
他一点也不严厉。
Fidel's style is more to try and tease the girls into listening to him. For instance, McKenzie likes to wear short shorts. So one day Fidel said, hey, if you're going out like that, I'll do it too. He grabbed scissors, and cut off the bottom of his T-shirt, and made it into a crop top. Then, he reached for his shorts.
菲德尔的风格更倾向于用戏弄的方式让孩子们听话。例如，麦肯齐喜欢穿短裤。所以有一天菲德尔说，嘿，如果你要那样出门，那我也穿那样。他拿起剪刀，剪掉了T恤的底部，把它变成了露脐装。然后，他伸手去拿短裤。
I cut them, and I stuck it up all the way up, like I stuck it up all the way up. Like hey, you're gonna to go to the street like that? Hey, let me go too. We can go together.
我剪了它们，然后把它们提得很高，就像是提得很高很高。嘿，你要那样去街上？嘿，让我一起去。我们一起去。
Was she embarrassed? What'd she say?
她觉得尴尬吗？她说什么了？
She said, I'm not going to go with you like that.
她说，我才不要那样和你一起去。
My dad is like-- he's very obnoxious.
我爸爸就是……他非常惹人嫌。
Isabella is always, you're annoying me. Even Jennifer said, stop being annoying. And even McKenzie says, stop annoying. It's love. I don't know if it's annoying to them, but it's love.
伊莎贝拉总是说，你烦死我了。甚至珍妮弗也说，别烦人了。连麦肯齐也说，别烦了。这是爱。我不知道她们是不是觉得烦，但这确实是爱。
In January, on the first day of President Trump's second term, he declared a border emergency, moved to end birthright citizenship, and suspended refugee admissions. Within weeks, the TV was full of ads, Department of Homeland Security Secretary Kristi Noem telling immigrants--
一月，唐纳德·特朗普第二个任期的第一天，他宣布进入边境紧急状态，采取行动终止出生公民权，并暂停了难民入境。几周内，电视上到处都是广告，国土安全部部长克里斯蒂·诺姆告诉移民——
Leave now. If you don't, we will find you, and we will deport you. You will never return.
现在离开。如果不走，我们会找到你们，并将你们驱逐出境。你们永远无法回来。
Jenni had tried to find out everything about the Trump administration's plans. She'd read about Project 2025, and worried that if Fidel got picked up, he'd get stuck in a detention center, and it would ruin their lives. She'd heard horror stories, people being treated cruelly, getting abused. She couldn't stop picturing Fidel in there, in a cell with nowhere to sleep, no way to call. What if he came out a completely different person than he went in? She didn't want that for her sweet goofball of a husband. And would they have to spend their life savings to get him out? One couple they were friends with, the husband had gotten picked up.
珍妮试图打听关于特朗普政府计划的一切。她读到了“2025计划”，担心如果菲德尔被抓，他会被困在拘留中心，那将毁了他们的生活。她听过恐怖故事，人们受到残酷对待，被虐待。她不禁想象菲德尔身处其中，在一个没有地方睡觉、无法打电话的牢房里。如果他出来时变得完全不是原来的那个他了呢？她不想让她的那个甜蜜又笨拙的丈夫遭遇这些。而且他们是否得花光积蓄把他救出来？他们的一对朋友夫妇中，丈夫就被抓了。
They are over $50,000 in debt to attorneys. So you have destroyed, absolutely destroyed, this couple's life.
他们背负了超过5万美元的律师债。所以你已经彻底、完全地毁了这个夫妇的生活。
But Fidel told her he was willing to take the risk. He wanted to stay.
但菲德尔告诉她，他愿意承担风险。他想留下来。
And I said, so what do you want to do if you get picked up? Tell me what that looks like. So if we're just going to take our chances and we're going to stay, what happens if you get picked up? During that conversation, he said, I don't want you to spend any money to get me out, if he were to get picked up for anything.
我说，那么如果你被抓了你想做什么？告诉我那会是什么样子。如果我们要赌一把并且要留下来，如果你被抓了会发生什么？在那次对话中，他说，如果他因为什么原因被抓，他不希望我花任何钱去把他弄出来。
And I told him that he needed to tell his children that. Because if something were to happen, they would never forgive me. They would never forgive me for leaving him in there. Even if it was a decision that he and I made together, they would never forgive me. Because I'm the fixer for all these kind of things.
我告诉他，他需要告诉他的孩子们。因为如果真的发生了什么，她们永远不会原谅我。她们永远不会原谅我让他留在那里。即使那是我和他共同做出的决定，她们也绝不会原谅我。因为我是解决这类事情的人。
Fidel felt that unless ICE was here-here, like in their small suburban town an hour outside of Raleigh, North Carolina, there really wasn't much to worry about. He figured the odds were with him. When they were having these conversations last winter, ICE had arrested less than half of 1% of the 14 million undocumented people in the country.
菲德尔觉得，除非ICE（移民海关执法局）直接到这里来——就在他们离北卡罗来纳州罗利市一小时车程的小郊区，真的没什么可担心的。他觉得胜算在他这边。去年冬天他们进行这些谈话时，ICE逮捕了全美1400万无证移民中不到0.5%的人。
Besides, Trump was still saying that he was going after criminals, and Fidel didn't see himself as a criminal. He was a tax-paying dad, a successful electrician helping build public schools in the area. If Fidel got detained and deported, it'd be disastrous, but it was just so unlikely.
况且，特朗普一直说他针对的是罪犯，而菲德尔并不认为自己是罪犯。他是一个纳税的父亲，一个成功的电工，帮助在该地区建造公立学校。如果菲德尔被拘留和驱逐出境，那将是一场灾难，但这实在太不可能了。
Jenni wasn't going to wait around for Fidel to agree with her to make a plan. She started prepping on her own, holed herself away in her home office, and got to work putting together these massive purple binders of pay stubs, receipts, paperwork.
珍妮可不会等着菲德尔同意才制定计划。她开始独自准备，把自己关在家庭办公室里，开始整理这些巨大的紫色活页夹，里面塞满了工资单、收据、文件。
His birth certificate, a copy of all of his passports and identification, copies of our tax returns.
他的出生证明，所有护照和身份证件的复印件，我们税表的副本。
Hundreds of documents, in the case of his arrest or detainment, that she could use to prove that Fidel had been here, working, not committing crimes, for the past 30 years. She labeled the binders "in case of emergency." Fidel found it all a little bit--
数百份文件，万一他被逮捕或拘留，她可以用这些证明菲德尔过去30年来一直在这里，在工作，没有犯罪。她在活页夹上贴了标签：“紧急情况下”。菲德尔觉得这一切有点——
Annoying. Like annoying, like she wanted me to go, like she wanted me to go.
烦人。就是烦人，好像她希望我走，好像她希望我离开一样。
Did it hurt your feelings, this idea that she might want you to go?
这种觉得她可能想让你走的想法伤害到你的感情了吗？
I guess, yes. Just like, why do you want me to go? It's like, my life is in here. That is-- it hurts.
我想，是的。就是，为什么你想让我走？我的生活就在这里。那真的很……让人受伤。
Did you ever tell her that it hurt your feelings?
你告诉过她这伤害了你的感情吗？
No, I think it's like a-- like a proud, how you say? Proud? Proud thing. I'm not going to tell you what hurts.
没有，我觉得这是一种……怎么说呢？自尊？自尊心作祟吧。我不会告诉你哪里受伤了。
McKenzie and Bella could understand both parents arguments over whether he should go. But it was easier to side with their dad. He was saying there was nothing to worry about, everything was fine, and things could stay the same.
麦肯齐和贝拉能理解父母双方关于他是否应该走的论点。但她们更容易站在父亲这边。他说没什么可担心的，一切都很好，事情可以保持不变。
Me and Bella both swayed to the side of keeping my dad in the United States.
我和贝拉都倾向于让爸爸留在美国。
We kind of just didn't want him to go, so we kind of just-- I don't know if we avoided it, more like we just didn't really think about it, I guess.
我们只是不想让他走，所以我们只是……不知道算不算逃避，更像是我们真的没往那方面想，我想。
It'd be a shadow, and I definitely feel like it would come out, though, when we were at home, and if we weren't doing anything. If we were being a family, it would be like, oh, this might come to an end.
那就像一片阴影，但我确实感觉它会浮现出来，尤其是在我们在家的时候，如果我们没做什么事的话。如果我们正在像一家人一样相处，就会觉得，噢，这可能要结束了。
They'd been sitting with some version of this dread for over five years. They first learned that their dad might have to move to Mexico back in 2020, when Donald Trump was running for a second term. They were in fifth and seventh grade, and their mom, Jenni, was scared of what Trump would do with immigration in a second term and felt like she had to prepare the girls, who at that time had no idea at all that their dad was undocumented, or that he might have to leave. Of course, this was life-altering news.
她们带着这种恐惧生活了五年多。她们第一次得知爸爸可能不得不搬回墨西哥是在2020年，当时唐纳德·特朗普正在竞选第二个任期。她们那时上五年级和七年级，她们的妈妈珍妮担心特朗普在第二个任期内会在移民问题上做什么，并觉得必须让孩子们做好准备，那时的她们根本不知道爸爸是无证移民，也不知道他可能不得不离开。当然，这对她们来说是改变生活的新闻。
I was crying, I know that.
我哭了，我知道。
Were you crying too?
你也哭了吗？
Yeah, definitely.
是的，肯定的。
I distinctly remember trying to hide the fact that I was crying by putting my hand right here, and then I would lay down on the desk, and my arm like that. Like, I did not want to be crying. So yeah, the thing is, I don't like the feeling of it on my face, really. So when I try to cry, I try to get it before it gets like down to here area. So--
我清楚地记得我试图隐瞒我正在哭的事实，用手捂在这儿，然后趴在桌子上，像那样把手臂放好。我想说，我不想哭。所以，问题是，我真的不喜欢脸上那种感觉。所以当我试着哭的时候，我会尽量在眼泪流到这儿之前就把它们抹掉。所以——
Their parents asked them not to tell anyone, which made this big news feel even heavier. Suddenly they felt different from the other kids at school.
父母要求她们不要告诉任何人，这让这个重大的消息感到更加沉重。突然间，她们觉得和学校里的其他孩子不一样了。
Things started to also just make more sense. Because also people describe, when you're married, the man's supposed to drive. And then I'm like, oh, but my dad doesn't drive. And then I was like, oh, that's probably why. Because he doesn't have a license.
事情开始变得有道理了。因为人们常说，当你结婚时，男人应该开车。然后我想，噢，但我爸不开车。然后我就想，噢，那大概就是原因。因为他没有驾照。
Fidel does drive. But when the family's together, Jenni's the one who drives.
菲德尔确实开车。但当全家在一起时，是珍妮开车。
I started understanding why we didn't travel as much. I heard my friends all the time saying they traveled to Canada, or Europe, or whatever. I don't know what a five-year-old is doing in Europe, but whatever. But it was like I could hear them traveling, and I was like, why don't we ever travel? And so I kind of started understanding why.
我开始明白为什么我们不怎么旅行了。我经常听到朋友们说他们去加拿大，或欧洲什么的。我不知道一个五岁小孩在欧洲干嘛，但随便吧。但我能听到他们旅行，我就想，为什么我们从不旅行？所以我就开始明白原因了。
With this new understanding came fear. McKenzie started having nightmares about ICE.
伴随着这种新的理解而来的是恐惧。麦肯齐开始做关于ICE的噩梦。
They come and break into the house, almost like a movie. And then we know that they're coming, but we're all hiding in the house behind the TV. And then they find my dad, and I'm standing, hiding away. But I still see him, and they're just taking him away.
他们破门闯入家里，就像电影里一样。我们知道他们要来了，但我们全都藏在屋里电视机后面。然后他们找到了我爸，我站着躲在一边。但我依然看着他，他们就这样把他带走了。
That was in seventh grade. She's older now, but the nightmares returned when Trump took office again and she started overhearing her parents arguing. The situation was back.
那是七年级。她现在长大了，但当特朗普再次上任，她开始偷听到父母争吵时，噩梦又回来了。那个“情况”又回来了。
Do you guys ever talk about it amongst yourselves?
你们之间谈论过这件事吗？
I actually don't think we've talked about it.
其实我觉得我们没谈论过。
Yeah, no, we don't really talk about it.
是的，不，我们真的没怎么谈论过。
I think that we both do the same thing, where--
我觉得我们都在做同样的事，就是——
We try to avoid it in conversation.
我们试图在谈话中避免它。
I don't think we've ever brought it up willingly just to talk. Because it's just like, we're going to sit there and be sad.
我想我们从未主动提起过它。因为这就像是，我们只会坐在那儿变得伤心。
Instead, they dealt with the tension in the house by distracting themselves.
相反，她们通过分散注意力来处理家里的紧张气氛。
I think-- there was at one point, McKenzie had a running phase, where she ran every night.
我想……有段时间，麦肯齐有一段跑步期，她每天晚上都跑。
Oh, yeah, I ran every night, during the winter time. Because Trump had just won, and then all these things were just running in my head.
噢，是的，我冬天的时候每天晚上都跑。因为特朗普刚赢了，所有这些念头都在我脑子里打转。
And she doesn't like running in the light, because she doesn't like people looking at her while she runs.
而且她不喜欢在光线下跑，因为她不喜欢跑步时有人盯着她看。
Exactly.
正是如此。
So when it'd get dark, she would run, and I would ride my bike next to her. Because I cannot run for anything, like it's so bad. But yeah.
所以当夜深了，她就去跑，我就骑自行车在她旁边。因为我跑步真的不行，简直太差了。但是的。
Would you guys talk too?
你们会聊天吗？
I think when I would be walking, we would talk, but it would be about school drama.
我想当我走的时候，我们会聊，但都是关于学校的八卦。
They'd run and bike for as long as they could, until it was too late to be out, and only then would they go home, traipse past their parents watching the evening news, and go upstairs.
她们尽可能久地跑啊、骑啊，直到太晚不能在外，那时她们才回家，踩着步子从看晚间新闻的父母身边经过，回到楼上。
It's not like I don't care about what's going on. It's more like it's just sad. And it's like, well, if you're going to be sad forever, or you're going to block it out, and just move on or something.
并不是说我不关心正在发生的事情。更像是这件事太令人悲伤了。就像，要么你会永远难过，要么你会把它屏蔽掉，然后继续生活什么的。
But the Trump administration did not want anyone to block out what they were doing. They wanted their immigration policies splashed across headlines and social media. They wanted them embedded in the nation's psyche, especially in families like this one. In March, the headlines were, Kilmar Abrego Garcia was mistakenly deported from Maryland to the notorious CECOT prison in El Salvador, along with 260 other people. The Trump administration added a self-deport button to the Customs and Border Protection app.
但特朗普政府可不希望任何人屏蔽掉他们的做法。他们希望他们的移民政策充斥着头条新闻和社交媒体。他们希望这些深深扎根于国家的心理，尤其是像这样的家庭。三月，头条新闻是：基尔玛·阿布雷戈·加西亚被错误地从马里兰州驱逐到了萨尔瓦多的臭名昭著的CECOT监狱，和他一起的还有其他260人。特朗普政府在海关和边境保护局的应用程序上增加了一个“自愿遣返”按钮。
Meanwhile, McKenzie was working weekends at Jersey Mike's. Bella was on the wrestling team. She and Fidel practiced grappling in the living room. He drove the girls to soccer games most weekends, cheering them on from the sidelines.
与此同时，麦肯齐周末在Jersey Mike's打工。贝拉在摔跤队。她和菲德尔在客厅练习擒拿。他周末大部分时间开车送孩子们去踢足球，在场边为她们加油。
Jenni taped little cards all over the front door on red construction paper, what to do if ICE comes knocking. Bella's 15th birthday was coming up, her quinceañera year, a big deal. Fidel and Jenni kept asking her about plans and ideas for the party, but she just kept pushing it off. At one point her parents even asked her, do you want a quince, or a car instead? Quince, she said.
珍妮在门前贴满了红纸制的小卡片，写着如果ICE来敲门该怎么办。贝拉的15岁生日快到了，她的“成年礼”之年，这可是件大事。菲德尔和珍妮一直问她派对的计划和想法，但她一直拖着。有一次父母甚至问她：你想要个成年礼，还是想要辆车？成年礼，她说。
I wanted one. But then I was like-- I was thinking about it, and I was like, what if he's not actually there for it? The dad is a big part of a quince. So I was like, what if he's not even there to celebrate it with me? Do I really want that? And I was like, I don't want a quince without him. So I didn't want to go through all the trouble of planning it, and then him not being there. So I was like, oh, I don't want to do this anymore. So--
我想要一个。但后来我……我一直在想，我心想，如果他到时候不在场怎么办？父亲在成年礼上是很重要的角色。所以我心想，如果他甚至不能在那儿跟我一起庆祝怎么办？我真的想要那样吗？然后我想，没有他我不想办成年礼。所以我不想费尽心机去策划，结果他却不在场。所以我想，噢，我不想办这个了。所以——
She called it off.
她取消了它。
I was not happy with that. It's like, I just want to do the party. I just want to see Isabella happy. But it is what it is. We need to plan it and everything, and have that stress. And for some reason it would happen and oh, your dad is not going to be there in the party. I think that would be a pretty bad thing to happen.
我对此一点也不高兴。我想，我只是想办派对。我只是想看到伊莎贝拉开心。但事实就是这样。我们需要策划它什么的，并承担那种压力。万一发生了什么，噢，你爸爸不能参加派对。我觉得那将是一件非常糟糕的事情。
Valerie Kipnis. Coming up, the pressure on the family increases, and the kids overhear something they haven't heard before. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯。接下来，家庭的压力增加，孩子们听到了她们以前没听过的事情。这将在芝加哥公共电台的一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. Today's program, Under One Roof, stories of families going through experiences, where different family members see things very differently from each other. We're in the middle of Valerie Kipnis's story about the Rivera family trying to figure out if they should self-deport. We pick up in the spring.
这是《美国生活》。今天的节目，“同一屋檐下”，讲述的是那些经历着的家庭故事，其中不同的家庭成员看待事情的角度非常不同。我们继续瓦莱丽·基普尼斯关于里维拉一家试图决定是否应该自愿遣返的故事。我们从春天接续。
The stalemate between Jenni and Fidel was getting worse. Every day, Jenni went online, trying to think through a possible move. She scrolled through houses in Mexico, tried to find towns they could afford with expat communities. She looked up English language schools for the girls, who don't speak Spanish. She showed all this to Fidel, and he went along with it, begrudgingly. He didn't think it was necessary.
珍妮和菲德尔之间的僵局越来越严重。每天，珍妮都在网上寻找可能的出路。她浏览着墨西哥的房子，试图找到他们能负担得起且有外籍人士社区的城镇。她查询了孩子们上的英语学校，她们并不会说西班牙语。她把这些都给菲德尔看，他勉强同意了。他认为没必要。
And all these months of pressure, of arguing, culminated in this one fight, when Jenni and Fidel found themselves standing across from each other in the living room, yelling. No one can remember what started the fight. What they do remember is the yelling.
而这几个月的压力、争吵，在一次争吵中达到了顶峰，珍妮和菲德尔发现他们站在客厅对面，大声吼叫。没人记得争吵是怎么开始的。他们记得的只有吼叫。
I think the kids are upstairs, and they hear that stuff.
我想孩子们在楼上，她们听到了这些。
How do you know?
你怎么知道？
I'm pretty sure they hear. We yelling pretty loud stuff. We're yelling pretty loud each other. It's like-- I'm thinking, in the top of my head, it's like, are you crazy? It's not going to happen. We yell at each other.
我很确定她们听到了。我们吼得很大声。我们冲着彼此吼得很大声。就像……我在想，在我的脑子里，我在想：你疯了吗？这不会发生的。我们冲着彼此吼叫。
Was that unusual for you?
那对你们来说不寻常吗？
Yes, that is unusual. Because, like I said, 17 years, we never yell on each other, right? That is when my head start thinking, she's over stressed. And it's like this is when-- now is when my head start to kick in, it's like, I need to do something, I need to-- I need to start thinking.
是的，那很不寻常。因为正如我所说，17年了，我们从没冲对方吼过，对吧？当我的头脑开始思考时，她压力太大了。这是……现在是我的头脑开始介入的时候了，就像是，我需要做点什么，我需要……我需要开始思考了。
The truth was, Fidel's resolve was starting to unravel. He had always believed that until job sites near him got raided, he was OK. There was nothing to worry about. But by the spring, ICE arrests in North Carolina had more than doubled since the same time last year. He started counting heads at work. Was anyone missing? He started getting nervous whenever he was driving, or when he saw a cop.
事实是，菲德尔的决心开始动摇了。他一直认为只要附近的工作点没被突袭，他就没事。没什么可担心的。但到了春天，北卡罗来纳州的ICE逮捕人数比去年同期增加了一倍多。他开始在工作中数人头。有人缺席吗？他开始在开车时或看到警察时感到紧张。
In May, the Trump administration created Project Homecoming, offering people $1,000 and a free plane ticket to leave the country. They regularly posted triumphant videos on social media of agents with gaiters and guns blasting doors, raiding people's homes and workplaces, of people in shackles being led onto planes, often to the tune of trolling music.
五月，特朗普政府启动了“回家计划”，提供1000美元和一张免费机票让人们离开该国。他们定期在社交媒体上发布特工带着护具和枪支冲破门、突袭人们的家和工作场所的胜利视频，人们戴着镣铐被带上飞机，往往伴随着嘲弄的音乐。
[POLICE CHATTER]
[警笛嘈杂声]
Come to the front door.
出来到前门。
Fidel watched those videos and others that were going viral, and they had the effect on him that the Trump administration probably wanted. They scared him.
菲德尔看了这些和其他正在疯传的视频，它们对菲德尔产生了特朗普政府可能想要的效果。它们吓到了他。
I think I saw it on the TV, when the kids separated with the parents, that videos, where they grabbed the mom, and separate the mom, and the kids stay crying all day, the mom never coming back, and the kids thinking, what am I going to do? It's like, I don't want that feeling for my kids. I don't want to give them that feeling.
我想我在电视上看到了，当孩子和父母分开时，那些视频，他们抓住了妈妈，分开妈妈，孩子们整天哭，妈妈再也没回来，孩子们心想，我该怎么办？就像，我不想让我的孩子有那种感觉。我不想给她们那种感觉。
One day, McKenzie saw reports on social media that ICE was in their area. She texted her parents. Fidel texted her back a goofy face emoji and, "don't worry about it." But it bothered him that she was thinking about this stuff.
有一天，麦肯齐在社交媒体上看到报告说ICE就在她们的地区。她给父母发了短信。菲德尔给她回了一个滑稽的表情符号，“别担心”。但他很困扰她竟然在想这些事。
I called him in June to check in. His friend's brother, who worked nearby, his job site had just been raided. And Fidel was preoccupied with two bills in front of the North Carolina legislature that would force state agencies like Highway Patrol to cooperate with ICE.
六月我打电话给他询问情况。他在附近工作的朋友的兄弟，工作点刚被突袭了。菲德尔正忙于北卡罗来纳州立法机构面前的两项法案，这将迫使像公路巡警这样的州机构与ICE合作。
Almost all last year, when Jennifer tell me, it's like, hey, when we start to make a plan, it's like, oh, I don't think it's nothing going to happen. But now, it's-- especially with these two bills. It's like, oh, I think it's-- I think my wife is right.
去年几乎整年，当珍妮弗告诉我时，像是：嘿，我们什么时候开始制定计划，就像是：噢，我觉得什么都不会发生。但现在，它是……尤其是这两个法案。就像是：噢，我觉得……我觉得我妻子是对的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wow, Fidel, last time that you and I spoke, you were kind of like, I don't know, she's a bit dramatic, I don't know if I need to do this.
哇，菲德尔，上次你和我交谈时，你有点像是：我不知道，她有点夸张，我不知道我是否需要这样做。
Yeah.
是的。
It's a big change.
这是一个巨大的变化。
Yes, it's-- every day I was like a little bit processing. It's like I need to start thinking and I need to change my switch.
是的，这……每天我都在一点点处理。就像我需要开始思考，我需要改变我的开关。
The last straw for Fidel was Alligator Alcatraz.
菲德尔最后的底线是“短吻鳄恶魔岛”（指拘留中心）。
I'm not-- I'm not going to be in one of that places. That is my switch. When Jennifer told me five months ago, hey, they're going to build detention centers. And even I told her, it's like, are you crazy? They're not going to build. And three months later, it's like, we got the first one. And I'm pretty sure maybe it's going to be more.
我不会……我不会去那种地方的。那是我的开关。当珍妮弗五个月前告诉我：嘿，他们要建拘留中心。甚至我还告诉她：你疯了吗？他们不会建的。三个月后，就像是，我们有了第一个。而且我很确定可能还会有更多。
After all those months, all those conversations, Fidel finally agreed that he needed to leave, maybe with the family, but probably alone. So in June, he sat Jenni down.
经历了那几个月，那所有的谈话，菲德尔最终同意他需要离开，也许和全家一起，但很可能独自一人。所以六月，他让珍妮坐下。
The Saturdays or Sundays, we sit on the couch in the mornings. And I-- I told her, it's like, OK, fine, I'm going, I gotta go. Yeah. It's like, are you sure? And I say, yes. Like, the face changes right away.
周六或周日，我们早上坐在沙发上。我告诉她：好吧，行，我要走了，我得走了。是的。就像：你确定吗？我说：是的。就像，脸马上就变了。
Like she was relieved?
就像她感到如释重负？
Like a relief on her face, like, I think finally he understands. Like, finally. Yeah, but yeah. It's-- it's good, it's fine.
就像她脸上的一种如释重负，就像：我想他终于明白了。就像是终于。是的，但是是的。这……这很好，没问题。
This is what Jenni had been asking for all along. She's had such a hard time watching the Trump administration's war against immigrants escalate.
这就是珍妮一直以来想要的。看着特朗普政府对移民的战争升级，让她感到如此艰难。
But I've already been living in that fear and panic for 16 years, and I can't take any more. And maybe if I was a different person, I could wait it out. But I'm not. I am who I am.
但我已经在那样的恐惧和恐慌中生活了16年，我再也受不了了。也许如果我是个不同的人，我可以熬过去。但我不是。我就是我。
Something I think a lot is, people who do support Trump, if they were to think about this, they would feel like this is the point, is for people to be scared, is for people to leave, to self-deport, right? And it feels like-- is there a part of you that feels like this is admitting, like raising the white flag, and being like, you won? Or no?
我想的一件事是，支持特朗普的人，如果他们思考这一点，他们会觉得这就是目的，就是让人们感到害怕，就是让人们离开，自愿遣返，对吧？这感觉……你心里有没有一部分觉得这像是承认，就像举起白旗，说：你赢了？或者没有？
Yeah. Feels like you're giving up. It absolutely does. But if you'd been living in the purgatory that we've been in for all of these years, and you weren't able to make any plans for your future, for your kids' future, for your life, at some point, everybody is going to raise that white flag. And so I am. I just can't do it anymore.
是的。感觉就像你在放弃。绝对是的。但如果你像我们这些年来一样生活在炼狱中，并且无法为你的未来、为你孩子的未来、为你自己的生活做任何计划，在某个时候，每个人都会举起那面白旗。所以我就举了。我只是再也受不了了。
Meanwhile, Fidel has spent decades feeling like even though he entered the country illegally, he was here now, and he'd do things by the book, work hard at his job, pay into Social Security he'll never get back, support his kid's soccer team and Girl Scout troops, hoping that the people of America would see what he and so many other people were doing, that they were already contributing to this country, and embrace them, and make them full citizens. But now, he realized that deal was never going to come. In fact, a lot of people didn't even want him here.
与此同时，菲德尔几十年来一直觉得，即使他是非法入境，但他现在在这儿，他会按部就班做事，努力工作，缴纳他永远拿不回来的社会保障金，支持他孩子的足球队和童子军，希望美国人民能看到他和许多其他人所做的，他们已经在为这个国家做出贡献，拥抱他们，让他们成为正式公民。但现在，他意识到那笔交易永远不会到来。事实上，很多人甚至不希望他在这里。
He couldn't stop thinking about how hard he'd worked to make it in this country, picking oranges and tobacco. He'd started as a sweeper at his electrical company, worked his way up for years.
他不禁想到为了在这个国家立足他有多努力，采摘橙子和烟草。他从电气公司的清洁工做起，多年来一步步爬上来。
I think that is one of the reasons I feel like I'm angry, is because you are at the top of your career.
我想这就是我感到愤怒的原因之一，是因为你处于职业生涯的顶峰。
Fidel's at the peak of his career, running projects and crews.
菲德尔正处于事业巅峰，负责项目和团队。
Like, I worked so hard. I worked so hard. Work, start from the bottom, and go all the way up. And now, I'm going to start again. But now, the difference is I'm 50 years old. I'm not 30 years old. My legs is not going to be the same. And my hands is not going to be the same.
就像，我工作太努力了。我太努力了。工作，从底层做起，一直爬到顶端。而现在，我要重新开始。但现在的不同之处在于我已经50岁了。我不再是30岁了。我的腿不会和以前一样了。我的手也不会和以前一样了。
Next, Fidel and Jenni told the girls their dad would leave after Christmas, and the girls didn't really take it seriously. They'd been talking about Fidel leaving for months. This just felt like another update, so far away. For months, Jenni had been gaming out their Mexico options, and they weren't great. There was the money. She had just a few more years, five years before she could get her full pension. If she moved away now, they could live comfortably in Mexico, but probably never could come back to live in the US again. They couldn't afford it. So she decided she probably wouldn't move. It wasn't worth it.
接下来，菲德尔和珍妮告诉孩子们爸爸会在圣诞节后离开，女孩们并没有把它当回事。她们已经谈论菲德尔离开几个月了。这感觉只是又一个更新，还很遥远。几个月来，珍妮一直在推算她们在墨西哥的选项，结果都不太好。钱是个问题。她离获得全额养老金还有几年，五年。如果她现在搬走，她们在墨西哥能过得舒服，但可能永远无法再回到美国居住了。她们负担不起。所以她决定她可能不会搬。不值得。
As for the girls, she couldn't find them a public school with a good English-speaking program. But she wanted this to be a family decision. So Jenni called the girls into the living room for a family meeting.
至于孩子们，她找不到一所英语教学质量好的公立学校。但她希望这能成为一个家庭决定。所以珍妮叫女孩们到客厅开家庭会议。
We were all sitting downstairs, over there on the couches. I'm sitting in the middle, and my mom's over there on that couch by herself, and my dad's sitting next to me.
我们都坐在楼下，那边沙发上。我坐在中间，我妈独自坐在那边的沙发上，我爸坐在我旁边。
And I think I'm on the floor.
而且我觉得我在地板上。
Yeah, I think you're on the floor.
是的，我觉得你在地板上。
Jenni held up her iPad. On it was the listing for a house in Mexico. She was like, check out this house I found, maybe we could all move down to Mexico together. Would you want to live there, go to school there? McKenzie, the older sister, was the first to respond.
珍妮举起她的iPad。上面是墨西哥一所房子的房源信息。她说：看看我找到的这所房子，也许我们全家可以一起搬到墨西哥去。你们想住在那里、在那里上学吗？麦肯齐，大女儿，是第一个回应的。
I think I said no to begin with. I was like, I don't want that. Didn't we have a whole thing, Bella?
我觉得我一开始就说了不。我当时说：我不想要那样。我们不是已经谈过整个事情了吗，贝拉？
She was so adamant that she did not want to move.
她非常坚定地表示她不想搬。
Oh, yeah. It was bad. I remember not wanting to leave the country at all. Because I mean, this is my only place that I've been-- born here, raised, North Carolina.
噢，是的。那很糟糕。我记得一点也不想离开这个国家。因为我是说，这是我唯一待过的地方——生于斯，长于斯，北卡罗来纳州。
Yeah.
是的。
So it was like, you're going to make me leave, when I've dedicated my work and my school to North Carolina, and to the United States? That didn't make any sense. I said, I don't want to leave. This makes-- I was like, it doesn't make any sense for me to want to go, because I'm-- this is my senior year. This is my last year at the school. You're not giving me enough time. And then my mom got mad, and she responded at me, your dad is dealing with this. It's causing me stress, it's causing the family stress. It's, like, intense around here because of what's going on.
所以就像是，你要让我离开，而我已经把我的努力和学习都奉献给了北卡罗来纳州，奉献给了美国？这毫无意义。我说，我不想离开。这……我心想，我想走这事毫无道理，因为我……这是我高三了。这是我在学校的最后一年。你没有给我足够的时间。然后我妈生气了，她回应我：你爸爸正在处理这件事。这给我带来了压力，给家庭带来了压力。因为正在发生的事情，家里很紧张。
And then Bella didn't say anything. I don't think my dad really said anything. I think me and my mom were just rapid firing against each other. And then Bella kind of came and defended me, I guess. She was like, I see why McKenzie doesn't want to go, and you need to just let her be for a little bit. And my mom was saying, oh, you need to come back here. We still need to talk. And then my dad probably said the same thing, and I was like, I don't really have anything to say. I don't want to go, and I don't want to hear about all your plans about moving.
然后贝拉什么也没说。我觉得我爸没说什么。我觉得我和我妈在互相猛烈炮轰。然后贝拉过来帮我辩护了，我想。她说：我明白为什么麦肯齐不想走，你只需要让她自己待一会儿。我妈说：噢，你得回到这里。我们还需要谈谈。然后我爸大概说了同样的话，然后我就说：我真的没什么好说的。我不想走，我也不想听关于你搬家的所有计划。
I said no to everything in general, like moving, thinking about moving, thinking about my dad leaving, thinking about the house, thinking about, I don't know, everything. I was saying, I don't want anything to happen. I just want it to stay how it is.
我对所有事情都说了不，比如搬家，考虑搬家，考虑我爸爸离开，考虑房子，考虑，我不知道，一切。我说：我不想让任何事情发生。我只是想让它保持原样。
I mean, I was chill with whatever. Honestly, that's what I said. I was like, I don't really care what happens. I do care, I do. But you can literally take me out of the country. I could care less where I go. Like, I'll stay here, I'll leave. I'll do online school. I don't know, I'll just-- I didn't really care for it. I do care. Stop looking at me like that.
我是说，我对什么都无所谓。老实说，这就是我说的。我说：我真的不在乎发生什么。我是在乎，我是在乎。但你可以真的把我带离这个国家。我不关心我去哪儿。就像，我会待在这里，我会离开。我会上网校。我不知道，我只是……我真的不在乎。别那样看我。
Why are you looking at her like that?
你为什么那样看她？
I'm not looking at her like anything. She just sounds weird.
我什么眼神都没看她。她听起来很奇怪。
I was going to do whatever my mom thought was best. Leaving or staying, that's what I was going to do. And I get why McKenzie didn't want to leave either. I think my mom was really upset about the fact that she didn't want to leave, but I get why she didn't. Because she is literally like one year away from 18. And you're not going to really make any new friends at a new school for senior year.
我打算做任何我妈认为最好的事情。离开或留下，这就是我要做的。我也明白为什么麦肯齐也不想离开。我想我妈对她不想离开的事实感到非常心烦，但我明白为什么。因为她离18岁只差一年了。而且在高三的新学校你真的不会交到什么新朋友。
Jenni had always thought that this was where the girls would land. The girls felt like Jenni was asking a question she already had the answer to. Fidel sat there quietly during this whole conversation, not saying much at all.
珍妮一直认为女孩们会是这种态度。女孩们觉得珍妮问的问题她自己早就有了答案。在整个谈话中，菲德尔安静地坐在那里，几乎什么也没说。
Did you secretly wish that everyone said, OK, let's all go? Or no?
你有没有私下希望大家都说，好吧，我们一起走？或者没有？
Honestly, yeah, I'd say, yeah, everybody, let's go. If McKenzie said, yeah, we can go. And Bella said, yeah, we can go. And Jennifer said, yeah, we can go. It's like, then I had, sure, let's go. But that's like a movie stuff. In the real life, it's not gonna-- it's not gonna happen.
老实说，会，我会说，是的，大家，走吧。如果麦肯齐说：是的，我们可以走。贝拉说：是的，我们可以走。珍妮弗说：是的，我们可以走。那就没问题，走吧。但这就像电影里的情节。在现实生活中，它不会……不会发生的。
Fidel's sister went to see the house in Mexico. It's four bedrooms with a small pool, not far from the beach. She called him afterwards and told him it was really nice, a smart investment. When Fidel heard, his heart dropped. There was no backing out now. He'd have to be there to sign the documents in September, in three weeks. He was really leaving. Jenni was out of town, and asked Fidel to be the one to tell the kids he'd be leaving in three weeks.
菲德尔的妹妹去看了墨西哥那所房子。有四个卧室和一个小游泳池，离海滩不远。她之后打电话告诉他那真的很棒，是一项精明的投资。当菲德尔听说时，他的心沉了下去。现在没退路了。他得在九月，三周内到那里签字。他真的要走了。珍妮不在城里，让菲德尔告诉孩子们他三周后要走。
He was nervous to tell them, so he kind of sidestepped the whole conversation, just said, so you know I might be leaving, right? They were like, yeah, that's what we've been talking about. And then he dropped it. A few days later, Jenni called the girls.
他告诉她们时很紧张，所以他有点回避整个对话，只是说：你们知道我可能要走了，对吧？她们说：是的，那正是我们一直谈论的事情。然后他就没再说了。几天后，珍妮给女孩们打了电话。
And then I'm sitting on the couch one day, and my sister's on a call with my mom, and then my mom says something about him leaving in September. And then McKenzie tells me, he's leaving in, like, mid-September. And I was like, what?
然后有一天我坐在沙发上，我姐姐在和我妈通话，然后我妈说了些关于他九月离开的事。然后麦肯齐告诉我，他要走……九月中旬。我就想，什么？
And then she goes and checks her calendar on the phone, and she's like, that's next month.
然后她去查了手机上的日历，她说：那下个月。
Yeah, I was like, what the heck, guys? I didn't know this.
是的，我就想，见鬼了，你们怎么这样？我不知道这点。
I visited the girls in August, weeks before his scheduled departure. McKenzie and Bella were processing this sudden new reality in real time.
我在八月拜访了女孩们，在预定离开的前几周。麦肯齐和贝拉正在实时消化这个突然的新现实。
I mean, in a year, I had time to get myself kind of ready for it. I was-- like I could spend a little bit more time with my dad. But he's leaving in a month, and there's not really much you can do in a month with your dad.
我是说，在这一年里，我有时间让自己准备好。我……就像我能多花点时间陪陪爸爸。但他一个月内就要走了，和一个爸爸在一起一个月其实做不了什么。
And that's literally how, probably, I'm going to think about it, when he's gone, I could have done more.
而且这就是……当他离开时，我大概会那样想，如果我多做点什么就好了。
Yeah.
是的。
It's like he's just going to disappear. Like, he's going to be here one day, and then he's going to be gone.
就像他就要消失了一样。就像，他有一天会在这儿，然后他就走了。
They were just starting to get their minds around it. For their whole lives, it had been the four of them. Now Fidel would be gone. What would graduation look like? What about wrestling on the weekends, and soccer, which was such a big part of their lives? Fidel was the soccer parent. He'd go to every game.
她们才刚刚开始想通。她们一生中都是她们四个在一起。现在菲德尔要走了。毕业会是什么样？周末的摔跤呢，还有足球呢，那在她们生活中占据了很大一部分。菲德尔是足球家长。他会参加每一场比赛。
I realize he's not going to be there for another tournament. (WHIMPERING) So--
我意识到他不会在那儿参加另一场锦标赛了。（抽泣）所以——
(WHIMPERING) Yeah. A whole soccer season, he's not going to be here.
（抽泣）是的。整个足球赛季，他都不会在这儿。
Well, he'll be here for the first part of it, barely. I hope he at least gets to come to one more game. Maybe.
嗯，他会在这儿待上一段时间，勉强地。我希望他至少能来参加最后一场比赛。也许。
He'll be going to a couple. But yeah.
他会去参加几场。但是的。
I remember, it was the other day, and my mom was still gone, and she was gone. And then my dad was in some place, I don't know, he was outside or something. And I realized, she's going to college next year. My mom's the only one that's going to be here, because my dad's going to be gone. So this is what my life is going to be like for three more years. Like, I'm not going to have anybody to just talk to. So yeah.
我记得，那天我妈还没回来，她当时走了。然后我爸在某个地方，我不知道，他在外面什么的。然后我意识到，明年她就要上大学了。我妈是唯一会在这里的人，因为我爸要走了。所以这就是我未来三年生活会有的样子。就像，我不会有任何可以聊天的人了。所以是的。
You guys are spreading telepathic messages to one another. What are they?
你们之间在传达心灵感应信息吗？那是什么？
No, I'm not spreading telepathic. I'm just sad, because I didn't even really think about that. OK, I guess I didn't think about how Bella was going to be here all by herself, without people.
不，我没有传达心灵感应。我只是伤心，因为我甚至没认真想过那一点。好吧，我想我没想过贝拉一个人在这里会是什么样，没有人陪着。
Yeah. Well, I'll have my sports to distract me from things. And I'll probably go to the gym, or something. I have my friends and everything. And I talk to my best friend about-- we'll tell each other everything. But it's just not going to be the same as my sister.
是的。好吧，我有运动来让我不去想那些事。我可能会去健身房什么的。我有我的朋友什么的。我和我最好的朋友说……我们互相说一切。但这不会和姐姐一样了。
Yeah, I guess-- that's the same for me. I don't-- well, personally, I don't tell my friends everything. I mostly just tell Bella everything.
是的，我想……我也是。我不……好吧，就个人而言，我不把一切都告诉朋友。我大多数时候只告诉贝拉一切。
The plan was Jenni would stay with the girls. She would work for five more years so she could get her pension, retire. Then she'd join Fidel in Mexico, in the city of Merida, in a nice little neighborhood with lots of expats, far from his family in Mexico. But that's what he wanted. He didn't want to feel like a failure, coming back to the same place all these years later. Jenni and the girls would visit him on school breaks.
计划是珍妮会和女孩们在一起。她再工作五年，这样她就能拿到养老金，退休。然后她会去墨西哥加入菲德尔，在梅里达市，在一个有很多外籍人士的不错的社区，远离他在墨西哥的家人。但这正是他想要的。他不想感到自己是个失败者，多年后回到同一个地方。珍妮和女孩们会在学校放假时去看他。
As his departure date approached, the girls started hugging their dad a lot more. Bella even watched one of his favorite TV shows with him, The Voice. Fidel's been acting differently too. He's imparting all the last-minute wisdom he can think of, how to change the car oil, how to fix the stove, how to get the barbecue to work just right.
随着他离开日期的临近，女孩们开始更多地拥抱她们的爸爸。贝拉甚至陪他看了他最喜欢的电视节目之一，《美国好声音》。菲德尔的表现也不同了。他在传授所有他能想到的最后一分钟的智慧，比如如何换车油，如何修理炉子，如何让烧烤架正常工作。
Make sure you know what is a screwdriver, and you know what is a wrench. But that is this part that got saddening, like angry, because I'm going to leave my kids. I think that is the stuff, when I got angry with myself, like, oh man, I need to leave my kids.
确保你知道什么是螺丝刀，你知道什么是扳手。但这就是令人伤心的部分，就像愤怒，因为我要离开我的孩子了。我想那就是，当我对自己感到愤怒的时候，就像：噢，天哪，我需要离开我的孩子。
How do you think your relationship will be, if you're not over here?
如果你不在这儿，你觉得你们的关系会怎样？
That is going to be a challenge. She's going to be here, I'm going to be there. And some days, they're going to feel alone. And some days I'm going to feel alone. And she's going to be-- I'm pretty sure some days, she's going to be really frustrated, because she got two teenagers. And I'm going to be over there by myself like, no, pretty much no responsibilities. You know? And she's going to have all the work.
那将是一个挑战。她在那儿，我会在这儿。有时，她们会感到孤独。有时我会感到孤独。她会……我很确定有时，她会感到非常沮丧，因为她有两个十几岁的孩子。而我会在那边一个人……基本没什么责任。你知道吗？而她要承担所有的工作。
He sucks talking on the phone.
他打电话烂透了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He does. I love my husband, he has a lot of great qualities. But on the phone, he's like, uh-huh, mm-hmm, yeah, OK. It is 100%, 100% going to suck for the next five years. There's no question about it. I wake up in the morning, and I have my coffee while I talk to my husband. And I talk to him before I go to bed at night. And I'm like, I don't know how I'm going to manage without him. I really don't.
确实。我爱我的丈夫，他有很多优秀的品质。但在电话里，他就像，啊哈，嗯哼，是的，好吧。接下来的五年里，那绝对会糟透了。毫无疑问。我早上醒来，一边喝咖啡一边跟我丈夫聊天。睡觉前我跟他聊天。我心想，我不知道没有他我该怎么办。我真的不知道。
Can you imagine your life there?
你能想象你在那里的生活吗？
I see my house, big house, empty. I think my only way to spend my time is working, work the most I can, 12 hours, 13 hours, 14 hours.
我看到我的房子，大房子，空荡荡的。我想我花时间的唯一方式就是工作，尽我所能地工作，12小时，13小时，14小时。
Why? So you don't have to be alone in the house? Or why?
为什么？为了不用一个人待在房子里？还是为什么？
Yeah. I don't need to be alone. And I don't need to be depressed, or thinking, and something else. Just stay busy, working.
是的。我不需要一个人待着。我不需要抑郁，或者想什么别的事情。只要保持忙碌，工作就行。
Since Trump took office, 1.6 million people have self-deported, at least according to the Trump administration. That $1,000 that they offer anyone who self-deports, Fidel refused it. He found it insulting. He didn't want his name part of any official list being used to prove Trump's success. Instead, he decided his own terms of departure, when and how.
自特朗普上任以来，至少根据特朗普政府的数据，已有160万人自愿遣返。他们提供给自愿遣返者的那1000美元，菲德尔拒绝了。他觉得那是一种侮辱。他不希望他的名字出现在任何被用来证明特朗普成功的官方名单上。相反，他决定了自己的离开条件，时间和方式。
I can leave for the front door, not the back door. I can live on my own terms. I leave happy, I leave my family happy.
我可以从前门离开，而不是后门。我可以按照自己的条件生活。我离开时很开心，我让我的家人开心。
He had planned to take off quietly, but Jenni and the girls refused to let him disappear without a trace, as if he hadn't been here all this time. So they threw a Farewell Fidel party, invited all his friends, his co-workers, and their neighbors to celebrate the last three decades.
他本来计划悄悄离开，但珍妮和女孩们拒绝让他像没在这里待过一样无声无息地消失。所以她们举办了一个“再见菲德尔”派对，邀请了他所有的朋友、同事和邻居来庆祝过去的30年。
On the day of the party, he disappeared for a while. When he showed back up, he had a massive pinata of Donald Trump, custom-made. They hung it in the backyard. Fidel swung at it, laughing.
派对那天，他消失了一会儿。当他回来时，他带着一个巨大的唐纳德·特朗普皮纳塔（装满糖果的纸糊玩偶），定制的。他们把它挂在后院。菲德尔笑着打它。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[BANGING]
[撞击声]
Ooh!
噢！
And Bella finished it off.
贝拉完成了最后一击。
[BANGING]
[撞击声]
Oh! What the heck?
噢！见鬼，怎么了？
Fidel left in October. He pushed back his departure date so he could be there for his 17th wedding anniversary, and for the first soccer tournament of the season.
菲德尔在十月离开。他推迟了离开日期，以便参加他们的17周年结婚纪念日，以及参加赛季的第一场足球锦标赛。
Valerie Kipnis is a producer on our show. A week after Fidel left, Jenni heard from the school that a father of two kids there was picked up by ICE and is in detention now.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯是我们节目的制片人。菲德尔离开一周后，珍妮听说学校里一个有两个孩子的父亲被ICE抓走了，现在在拘留中心。
Our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. Dana Chivvis edited Valerie's story. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Suzanne Gaber, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Mary Marge Locker, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, and Diane Wu.
我们今天的节目由莉莉·沙利文制作。达娜·奇维斯编辑了瓦莱丽的故事。参与制作今天节目的人包括菲亚·贝宁、迈克尔·科米特、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、苏珊·加伯、卡西·豪利、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、塞斯·林德、玛丽·马奇·洛克、托宾·洛、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、娜迪亚·雷曼、安东尼·罗曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Kathy Capp, Ashley DeAzevedo and American Families United, Vanessa Dojaquez-Torres, and Bell Woods.
我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢凯西·卡普、阿什莉·德阿泽维多和“美国统一家庭”、凡妮莎·多贾克兹-托雷斯和贝尔·伍兹。
Heather Gay, who you heard at the top of the show, has a new documentary series about the Mormon church that premiered this week called Surviving Mormonism. It's on Bravo.
你在节目开头听到的希瑟·盖伊本周首播了一个关于摩门教的新纪录片系列，名为《幸存摩门教》。在Bravo播出。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. A reminder, if you like our show, if you listen to us a lot, please consider signing up as a This American Life partner. Do it for the stuff you get. Bonus episodes, an archive of greatest hits right in your podcast feed, ad-free listening. Or do it simply because you want us to be able to keep making the show. Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交换中心（PRX）发送给公共广播电台。提醒一下，如果你喜欢我们的节目，如果你经常收听，请考虑注册成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴。为了你能得到的东西这样做。奖励剧集，在你的播客订阅源中直接获得精彩合集，无广告收听。或者仅仅是因为你希望我们能继续制作这个节目。在thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners加入。
Support for This America Life comes from Keurig coffeemakers, bringing families together and defying the Mormon God for 30 years. I'm kidding. They're not an underwriter.
《美国生活》的支持来自Keurig咖啡机，30年来让家庭聚在一起并违抗摩门教的神。我在开玩笑。他们不是承销商。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who loved his mother like crazy. Thought she was the best, until that day that he walked into her kitchen and saw a certain appliance there.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他疯狂地爱着他的母亲。认为她是最好的，直到他走进她厨房看到某个家电的那天。
And a good mom doesn't have a Keurig.
而且好妈妈是不会用Keurig的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。